good afternoon -- rules
committee for Monday June
seventeenth is hereby called
order sorry about that calling
please revise and audio video
recorded today's proceedings
as also being televised
matter sector please call
the roll Cooley Cunningham
Carillo flora Grayson
Kamlager-Dove here Maienschein
Mathis your quirk Silva
here from here Rivas
Wicks we have a quorum
we have consent agenda is
your emotional exception
a most works his works and
mission Mr mat the second
thank you very much --
matter center please call
the roll Cooley hi Cooley
aye Cunningham Carillo flora
-- three seven five Grayson
aye Kamlager-Dove Kamlager-Dove
I Maienschein Maienschein
aye Mathis aye Mathis aye
perks over hi quirk Silva
aye rumors Ramos I am Rivas
Wicks Wicks I --
Correo Acosta I know I
and so I think I just yeah
right -- the motion is passed
and this rules because you
jerk thank you very much